foreign
ly verify the atomic theory now we have
pictures pictures taken from standing
finally microscopes but in between there
were many partial results they gave us
indirect proof of the existence of atoms
Einstein in 1905 was able to show using
statistical mechanics that atoms were
probably the size that that we think
they are today 10 to the minus eight
centimeters and it took time and so I
think not in one flash we're going to
prove that the Multiverse theory is
correct or the string theory is correct
but the overwhelming weight of evidence
will point in a direction and let me
make another challenge another challenge
to everybody in this room
you are free to not like any of these
theories but if you don't like these
theories propose your own the second law
of Thermodynamics says that it's always
more difficult to create a theory than
to destroy ethereum you can dislike any
of these theories that we talked about
today but I challenge you come up with a
better one well there's a excellent
opportunity to introduce Roger into this
conversation
well I'm not a particle physicist so I
don't claim to have a better Theory than
String Theory although I'm pretty
disappointed by the conclusions I mean
just to mention how other theories have
taken a long time to confirm it's once
tells me nothing about String Theory I
mean string theory proposes the wrong
number of dimensions of space for
instance it proposes the wrong sign for
the cosmological constants for instance
all sorts of things which have come out
of string theory are just wrong now you
could get around this one way or another
I know people like to tuck all these
extra Dimensions into a little tiny ball
they haven't answered the question that
I've often raised in my books about that
which is that it doesn't really solve a
problem I mean there are big huge
problems facing string theory I didn't
quite know why we're talking about this
since with the Multiverse anyway because
string theory
is just is a particular Theory which I
don't think has much in the way of
support for it it's got a lot of people
who argue for it but that's not
scientific support there aren't
experiments which support String Theory
but that's really a different question
from the Multiverse isn't it are we are
we talking about string theory of the
Multiverse here
thank you criticize for being a
Multiverse Theory oh but I don't mind
because if even if you take a look at
Newton's laws of motion they are also in
some sense of theory with an infinite
number of possible solutions and
strength here is an infinite number of
solutions well so does Newton's Laws
matches equations they all have an
infinite number of solutions but how do
you make sense of it by looking at the
initial conditions that's how you can
prove that Newton's theory is correct by
starting with a baseball starting with a
rocket same thing with stream Theory you
start with the initial conditions of the
universe and then you can project into
the future the problem is experimental
we do not know the initial conditions of
the universe therefore we cannot
directly compare it to a Multiverse
Theory but that's an experimental
question which I think will be answered
as we have more and more satellites
detect things like gravity waves in
outer space
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Art
and ideas at IAI TV